OK.
Uh, hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming all the way down to Mandalay Bay
on a Thursday afternoon.
Um, and today,
uh, I have with me.
Uh, I'm Summit Thakur. I lead all of
product for Amazon's Sagemaker AI,
and today I have with me David Galitelli,
who is a senior specialist for generative AI
at AWS,
and Nikhil Singhal, who is a senior staff
ML engineer at Robinhood.
And together, we are going to talk about
how we can help you accelerate building agents
using Sage Maker Studio and Bedrock Agent
Core. Now,
before we talk about how we can help accelerate your
Asian development,
I would love to kind of take a step back
and look at some of the key adoption drivers,
which is driving adoption of agentic AI
across enterprises.
Enterprises today,
they are deploying agents to improve their
customer experience,
automate operational workflows,
and to even improve their employee productivity.
And very often,
the enterprises are choosing to use custom
models
to power these agents.
They take off the shelf foundation models
and then customize them on their private
data
to give them
specialized domain knowledge and enable
them for specific tasks.
Gardner predicts that over the next 3 years,
the usage of these custom models is
going to explode, with more than 50% of
enterprises
choosing to use custom models as compared
to just 1% a year ago.
And this upsurge in the model customization
is not a surprise. This is driven
by very broad accessibility and availability
of various state of the art fine tuning techniques
like reinforcement fine tuning,
preference tuning, and supervised fine tuning.
Using these techniques, our customers
are able to take their private data
and build this knowledge into the models in a
very cost effective way.
Some of these techniques, especially reinforcement
learning, have been quite instrumental
in not just imparting specialized knowledge,
but also giving these model critical reasoning
capabilities.
With these reasoning capabilities, a model
can now take an incoming request,
break it down into discrete steps,
execute those steps using tools,
aggregate the responses, and then plan the
next set of steps.
This continuous improvement loop of
thinking,
acting, and observing enables
a model to continuously make progress
towards its goal in a self-sufficient way.
And this is exactly what forms the bedrock
of the brain of your agentic workflow.
Now, I'm going to walk you through
how you can build an agent for yourself.
This is how an agent development workflow typically
looks like.
First,
you have to plan out
your entire Asian development workflow.
In this first step, you think about what
your use case is,
who are your target users,
what goals and objectives do you have,
and even set up a success criteria.
You often use the success criteria to
evaluate the performance of your customized model
against that of a base model.
Then you move on to the next step where
you gather and collect data for training,
validation, and evaluation.
Then you go on to set up a tuning
infrastructure and then tune, evaluate,
and customize your model candidates.
Once you identify a model candidate that meets
your success criteria, you push them into
production for inference.
And finally, you take this customized
model running in production and build an
agent on top.
AWS gives you several purpose-built
services to help you with each step of this
work. So you have Amazon
Sagemaker AI, which is a model development
service
that lets you tune, customize, evaluate,
and deploy foundation models for any use
case. Then
you have Bedrock, which lets you take these
custom models and deploy them onto
a serverless infrastructure, giving you
high cost performance and great ease of use
for inference.
And finally, you have the Bedrock agent
core suite of tools and services
that lets you
build, deploy, and monitor agents in production
on top of these custom models.
And now, I'm going to walk you through the experience
of how to use these services to build an agent for
yourself. Starting with the first
step. Planning and setting
up an evaluation criteria.
Customers often tell us that in this
step, there's a lot of inertia.
You have to not only choose one base
model among many base foundation models.
You also have to set up a robust evaluation
criteria
so you can ensure your models behave responsibly
and accurately in production.
This often requires expertise and
can take weeks if not months to get started.
To help customers overcome this hump,
we are pleased to announce.
A launch of a new capability in Sagemaker,
Sagemaker model customization agent, which
was launched in preview this week.
Using the SageMaker model customization agent,
you can now plan, execute, and reproduce
your end to end model customization workflow
using plain language instructions.
Here is how the experience looks like.
All you need to do is to go inside Sagemaker
Studio, which is the visual interface
for Sagemaker.
Open the chat interface of the model customization
agent and then describe your use case
in plain natural language.
Then, through a mutual discussion and
conversation with the agent,
you will eventually arrive at a model customization
workflow for your use case.
Once you and the agent mutually agree upon that
workflow,
the agent converts that workflow into a hardened
spec which is stored as a JSONL file.
This specification is then used to both
drive the workflow as well as reproduce it at any
point of time.
And now I'm gonna show you how this specification-driven
workflow looks like
uh inside Sagemaker Studio. So here is the landing
page of the chat interface.
You can see on your left, there's a progress
bar, which helps you see where you stand in
your customization workflow.
In the main chat area,
you see the agent,
uh, which greets you and then asks you certain
clarifying questions about your use case.
For example,
whom are you planning to target?
What success criteria do you have in mind?
Are there any challenges that you face today in
addressing this use case with other alternative solutions?
I am going to take an example
of building a customer service chatbot for
a pet store.
So what I tell this agent is, hey, I
want to build this customer service chatbot.
This is going to target my current
and potential customers of Petto who are inquiring
about my products and services.
And as far as success criteria goes,
I have a few things in mind.
I want this agent
to always respond to my customers in a
polite and empathetic tone.
I want this agent to be grounded in factual
correctness when it comes to producing
information about my catalog of products and services.
And I want these responses to be very clear
and succinct.
And my hope is by deploying this
customer service chatbot,
I can achieve a higher customer satisfaction
rate and a higher customer retention rate of at least
20%.
The agent takes all these inputs and
then asks me further clarifying questions.
For example,
What are the typical
prompt response pair that we expect this customer
service chatbot to receive in production?
I provided with a few examples which I
have in mind.
And as the conversation goes, the agent
finally determines
that the right technique to use in this case
is preference tuning, using DPO.
And it provides an explanation that, hey,
DPO is a good technique for this use case
because you want to align the tone
of your customer service chatbot
to match your brand voice, as well as
you want to ground this agent in factual correctness.
And you can meet both of these objectives if you
use DPO.
It goes on to then suggest a small language
model, which is a great fit for my use case. I'm
gonna choose the same model. It's a Lama 3.1
as an example.
And then finally it lays out the success
criteria.
It presents this criteria both in the form
of a simple text,
so it's a human readable, easy to understand
text, as well as in the form of
measurable success metrics.
As you might see, these success metrics are
aligned with the way I had described my use case.
So, it has defined success metrics around
measuring the politeness of the tone,
measuring the alignment of the tone
with my brand voice, making sure the
responses are succinct.
All these metrics are pretty much aligned with how I had
described my use case to the agent.
Now, once I and agent mutually agree upon
this success criteria, I'm going to hit approve,
and this will convert it into a hardened specification
file. Once
that specification is ready, we are ready to move on
to the next step,
which is to gather and prepare data.
In this step, customers often tell us that
sometimes collecting data can be quite costly
and cumbersome.
Other times it may just simply contain some
private and sensitive information, making it impossible
to use that data for training.
To help customers address this sh,
we announced
a new synthetic data generation capability
in Sagemaker AI.
It's also available in preview starting this week.
Using this new capability,
you can generate data which is grounded in
your context
completely privately and securely.
To use this capability,
all you need to do is to go back into the
model customization Asian chat interface.
And then provide your context.
You can choose to provide context in the form of a
few inline prompt response samples,
or you can point to a content repository in
S3,
which contains things like your PDF documents,
customer support tickets, log files, and
other things that you want to provide as a context.
The agent uses this context to
generate statistically similar data.
And also a data quality report, and all of
this process runs completely on a surveillance
infrastructure,
which means you don't have to manage any of the underlying
compute and it automatically
uh matches the size of your workload.
Here is how the experience looks like in the chat interface,
so it opens up
this input form asking you to provide some
inputs, for example, how many samples you want to
generate
and giving the S3 link for
the context repository.
Once you hit
start synthetic generation, it generates both the
data set and a data quality evaluation
report with a bunch of useful metrics.
Let's take a look at a few of those.
So you get something like diversity analysis,
which shows you how diverse your generated data
is and whether you have all your
demographic groups well represented without any
biases.
It also shows you certain quality statistics.
In this case, it's showing you the mean length
of responses generated in the synthetic
data set.
If you remember, I had asked the agent
to create a customer service chatbot for me
which produces clear, succinct responses.
Hence, looking at the mean length of responses
is an important success criteria or a metric
to look at in the synthetic data.
Also gives you access to a few of the responsible
AI quality metrics to make sure
that your generated data does not contain any
toxic, harmful or sensitive content.
Once you review these quality parameters,
you can proceed onto the next step,
which is to customize and evaluate the models.
In this step,
customers were telling us it's often
very hard to set up the right fine-tuning
infrastructure and then manage, scale and operate
this infrastructure over time.
And then as new fine tuning techniques
keep on coming up, you have to keep on experimenting
with those techniques, try out all those different
hyperparameter choices,
try to get the right cost performance, and all of this
process of iteration and experimentation can take
months. To
help customers quickly get to a fine-tuned
model, we announced a new
serverless reinforcement learning capability in Sagemaker
AI.
Using this capability, you can now fine-tune
a broad choice of popular open
weights and Amazon Nova models
using a host of fine-tuning techniques,
including reinforcement learning in a completely
serverless way.
This capability supports a
lot of popular openweight models like
Metalaa, OpenAI GPT
OSS,
Queen, Deep Sek, and Amazon Nova
model families.
It also supports a broad
suite of customization techniques. For example,
you can use reinforcement learning with verifiable
rewards
for domains like math, science,
code generation,
or structured data output generation,
where you can measure the output of a model
using a simple reward function.
And the reward score generated by this function
can then be used to adjust the model weights.
You can also use reinforcement learning with AI
feedback where instead of a reward function,
you can use a state of the art judge model
like a cloud sonnet model to evaluate
your model responses and generate a reward score.
We also support preference tuning
that lets you align your models to human preferences
by providing a data set consisting of a prompt
and a positive and a negative response as evaluated
by human evaluators.
This can be really useful if you're trying to align
your model to things like
helpfulness, to tone, to brand voice,
where human preference is super important.
And finally, you can run all these techniques, as I
said, in a completely surless way, which means
you don't have to procure, provision
or manage any GPU clusters.
You simply fire away your job
with a push button approach
with all the default hyperparameterss which have been
tested by the service to give you the best cost
performance,
and I'm gonna show you what that experience looks like.
So you go back into Sagemaker Studio and you go back
to the Jumpstart Model hub.
From the Jumpstart Model Hub, you get access to
a host of state of the art open weights and
proprietary foundation models.
I'm gonna choose the Metal Armor model as
an example.
Once you click on customized model, you're gonna see
a bunch of options.
We already saw customization using AI
agent as one of the user interfaces
a couple of slides ago.
Now I'm gonna show you the visual interface,
how to customize using UI.
So once I click on customize with UI, the screen
opens up where I have to give a few
minimal inputs. So first I need
to use the technique here I'm gonna choose reinforcement
learning with verifiable rewards.
Then I need to upload my training data set.
And finally, I need to choose a reward function.
I can either
choose from one among the many available
built-in reward functions.
Or I can write my own reward function
as well.
And if I have a reward function hosted
as a lambda,
I can bring that lambda in as well.
Once you have given these few minimal inputs,
you can just hit run. As you can see, all
the hyperparameterss have been filled up by default.
As I said, these recipes have been optimized
by AWS to make sure you get the best
cost performance on AWS hardware,
so you can just straight away go and hit the run button
and get a customized model.
Now, as you go about doing these experiments, you
would need a place to track
and compare these experiments side by side.
To help this,
to help with this problem, we have launched a surless
MLflow capability.
So you can track all your model customization
experiments using the server SML
flow and compare those experiments side by
side. This
capability gives you access to the familiar ML
flow interface.
The entire ML4 tracking server runs
in a completely serverless way, so there is no
compute to manage, and it's available at
no additional charge. It's free.
It's just there, available in studio, and I'm gonna
show you the experience.
So once you launch a fine-tuning job and you go and
open up the job details page, you can
see some of the metrics which already start
appearing on the job details page,
like training loss and validation accuracy. All
these metrics are getting pulled from the server SML
flow. And
if you want to see more metrics and do a deep
dive, you can just click on these links
embedded right there to open up
MLflow in a separate browser tab.
There you can choose to go back into that
training run and do a deep dive, or
you can choose
multiple training runs side by side and do a comparison.
Once you have identified a model candidate after
running a bunch of experiments that you want to take forward,
now is the time for model evaluation
and make sure it meets the success criteria
you had determined at the beginning.
To run model evaluation,
we are pleased to also add another capability
of serverless model evaluation in Sage
Maker AI
that lets you evaluate and compare models
on multiple different dimensions in a completely serverless
way. You
might have already noticed I'm using the word serverless
with every capability, and that's what our vision is,
that every capability comes to you
without having to manage any infrastructure
throughout the model customization workflow.
With this surveillance model evaluation capability, you
simply can try out multiple different
evaluation techniques. For example,
you can run
industry standard benchmarks like MMLU.
You can choose to provide your own custom scoring
function. Or you can use
an LLM as a judge, where you can
use a clot sonnet or a GPT OSS
model as a judge to evaluate your model
responses and generate evaluation scores.
This capability not only collects the evaluation
results from your job, but also
summarizes them, aggregates them, and gives
you a summarized report comparing
the evaluation outcomes of your customized
model against that of the base model.
So you can quickly determine if your customization
is having the right impact on your model.
I'm gonna show this experience.
So here's the visual experience in studio.
You go back, you can see the
3 evaluation techniques on the top. I'm gonna
choose LLM as a judge.
And I'm going to choose clots on it as the
judge model.
Then I'm gonna specify the evaluation metrics
I want the re model to evaluate on.
I can choose among one of the many
quality and responsible AI metrics
which are available out of the box.
Or I can provide my own custom
metrics,
using a simple prompt.
You can use one of the built-in prompt templates,
write down a prompt for your custom metrics, or you
can write a prompt completely from scratch.
All of these options and flexibility is
completely available for you,
so you can choose to run your evaluation in the way
that best fits your use case.
Once you run the evaluation, it generates
this summary report which I was talking about,
that lets you compare the base model against
the fine-tuned model on all the summary statistics.
So you can quickly at a glance determine if your model
looks better after customization and move
on to the next step.
Wishes to deploy the model in production
for inference.
When it comes to deployment, Sagemaker
gives you two options,
easy to use options.
You can choose to deploy either
to Bedrock in a few simple clicks,
or you can deploy it on Sage Maker for
inference.
If you deploy on Sage Maker AI,
we do provide a bunch of
built-in capabilities to help you
improve your cost performance.
For example,
the Sage Maker inference comes with multi-
Lora deployments where if you
are training multiple different Lora adapters for
different use cases on top of the same base model,
you can bin pack all those Lora adapters
along with the base model onto the same instance
and set up
flexible independent scaling policies
for each adapter.
And that lets you
manage the right
performance, matching the demand patterns for each of
those Loa variants, as well as
reduce the cost by bin packing them onto the same instance.
Similarly, we also give other techniques like
dynamic adaptive speculative decoding,
uh, which lets you train
personalized draft models on your private
data. We call them eagleheads.
And using these eagle heads you can
then run inference against the incoming
prompts in a very cost effective way and
then pass on only a subset
of the generated tokens onto your main customized
model, which results this two-phase inference
results in the reduced overall cost of inference
with higher performance.
All these capabilities are built in as part of StageMaker
AI inference,
so I would definitely encourage you all to go
and give it a spin.
Now, once you are done deploying the model
for inference, now comes the final step.
Building the agent.
For this,
you use the Bedrock Asian core suite of tools
which works with both Bedrock endpoints as
well as the Sagemaker AI Inference endpoints.
With Bedrock Agent Core,
you get a bunch of tools and services to deploy
and monitor your agents in production.
First, Bedrock Asian Core is quite open.
It works with all the popular Asian development
software toolkits.
For example, you can bring Crew AI,
Landgraph, OpenAI SDK kit,
or you can use the Amazon's TransAent to
build your Asiantic workflow.
You can then deploy it onto the completely surless
runtime of the agent core.
This runtime allows you to run the agents
even for prolonged periods of time if you have
any batch process running behind the scenes.
Agent Core also gives you managed primitives
for memory,
both short term and long-term memory, so you can maintain
the context of your conversations as well as maintain
user preferences across sessions.
Now, as your agents run, they would typically
need to connect with multiple tools to complete
their task.
So agent code gives you a managed MCP gateway
to connect with these third party and first party tools.
In addition, it also gives you certain first party
tools out of the box. So for example, it gives you
a code execution runtime
and also a browser runtime
to browse the web and extract
information on the fly.
And finally, once you are done deploying the agent,
It gives you ways to just monitor the
agents and trace the entire
agentic call throughout the agentic workflow
and publishes these traces in the form of
an open telemetry format so you can bring your
own choice of observability
stack and
analyze and observe these traces.
One of the things I want to call out here in
the Bedrock Agent Core toolkit is the strands
SDK which really makes it easy
to develop your agentic workflow. This forms
the backbone of developing your agent.
And I think to show you how this can be done
very easily, I'm going to invite my friend Davidek
to come back on stage and show you a live demo.
Thank you, Summit.
Awesome.
Let me prepare my computer for the demo.
There we go.
Perfect.
So, we're just gonna go ahead and get started with the
demo. Let me give you like a brief rundown
of what this is gonna be all about.
Let's assume that you've been tasked
with the one challenge that we've seen
very common
across basically every customer that I've been working
with. Customers normally have a
business analyst or a business intelligence
persona.
They have a platform where they can throw
some questions against this. It could be a chatbot,
it could be just a web interface, a UI.
Normally, these business analysts, they have
great knowledge about the domain
that they wanna work on,
but not necessarily have the knowledge to know
how to write SQL queries from scratch.
So this is the task that we have. Our goal
is to work with this company.
This company, uh, basically
retail is in a new retail
industry. They have different tables, they have a
data catalog, and they wanna make sure
that the agents that they build
is a business analyst agent,
which can receive natural language questions
and output SQL queries, execute
the SQL queries and provide the
results once again in natural language
back to the user.
To do that,
we will use, of course,
Amazon Sage Maker AI.
Specifically, we will use the new capabilities that were
just introduced by Summit
in uh the Sage Maker Studio interface.
Of course, I'm gonna walk you through the UI
aspect of it, just for the sake of it being
easy for you to understand right now, but
all of that you see is also available via
code in the form of an SDK.
So what are the steps that we're gonna go through the demo?
We're gonna start by
choosing an off the shelf small
language model. Our goal is to use a small language
model to be cost effective,
to have a training that doesn't last for weeks
and instead lasts for hours,
maybe even minutes.
We will leverage synthetic data, so
the customer unfortunately didn't provide us with any
specific data or queries that they've already pre-built.
So we're gonna use the service data
generation capabilities in order to create a
synthetic data set.
We'll use that to customize the
small language model, evaluate it, deploy,
use it for an agent.
I think
we spoke already enough in, in general terms
about the demo.
So let's, let's just jump directly into
the UI and into the code.
In a second.
Perfect. Alright. I'm gonna zoom in
a little bit so that the people that are a little bit further away,
they can see.
Uh, at least a little bit better.
Cool. So, our journey, as
always, starts
within Sagemaker Studio.
So in Sage Maker Studio, when you jump in, you will have
all the different applications that are available,
the Jupiter labs, the studios, the Canvas,
the code editor, etc. etc. the new
serverlessML flow.
But our journey actually starts from the Jumpstart
Model hub, which you can access from the
Models tab here on the left.
There are some spotlight models, we're gonna use one
of them today.
Some of them are from Amazon, like the Nova 2
Doo family, which is now available also
in Sage Maker for customization, but
also open source models ranging
from Meta Lamas model to Quan models
to OpenAI models.
And you can actually drill down and see
which models are available for serverless
fine tuning
by selecting this filter here and
check the trainable serverless.
Right now we have 14 models
supported by the serverless capabilities, but you
can expect this number to grow a lot
in the next weeks and the next month.
Months.
So, what I'm gonna be doing today is that I'm gonna
start with the,
uh, I'm gonna choose the MetaLa 3.18
billion instruct. It's a model that I know
and I tested already, so this
is the model that I wanna go ahead and customize.
But of course for your use case, you can use whatever you want.
You can go as
little as, for example, 0.3 0.6
billion model.
23, 4 billion, etc. etc.
There's a lot of different models out there.
I'm just gonna go ahead and choose this one. And
I have two options, actually, I have three
options. There's the
code full version,
so customizing with code.
There's the UI driven optimization,
customization using the interface that
was shown before by Summit.
But today,
we're gonna focus on customizing
a model with an AI agent.
So, the very first thing is the agent
very simply is gonna tell us, hey,
what is the specific task that you
want to solve?
And we're gonna tell it. I should already have it
here in memory.
So let's just to
use this one.
So,
I want to fine tune a model to assist business
analysts and data analysts in writing correct
and efficient SQL queries, improving query
connectness, and reducing time to insights.
This is a message that I already had
pre-created, but virtually you can use any,
you can solve any kind of problem here,
because the goal of the agent behind the scenes is to
walk you through the steps.
So that you can understand and you can
get the best suggestions on how to solve
your problem. You will see, as
it was already shown by Summit, that this is
gonna be spec driven development. You're
gonna see a lot of files that detail step
by step
what the model, what the agent needs to do
in order to make sure that it solves the right
problem for you.
So, first of all, it already identifies, OK,
this is likely gonna be an SFT use case,
supervised fine tuning, and it tells you
why, right?
The SFT leverages labeled examples
of SQL prompts and correct answers,
so basically that's the prompt completion pairs.
This seems correct to me, but if I wanted to,
I could have told him,
hey, another good way to train
a model for SQL query generation
is, for example,
reinforcement learning with verifiable rewards.
Because I could be executing the queries behind the
scenes, getting the results, and using
that results, if correct,
to drive further the
uh fine tuning of the model.
So, for now, uh, for
some reason it's asking me again, so we'll just,
uh, say it again.
So, we're gonna be using SFT and you're gonna see
that the very next step is gonna be asking a little bit
more questions about,
you know, what does the, uh, what, what
should be the data that we want to use. So, first,
the first step is selecting the model. It
remembers that I'm using 3.18
billion. So, I'm gonna go ahead and use
this model, of course,
accepting the license agreement in this
case. And then the next step is,
OK, how do I tell it which data I want
to use.
In this case, I don't have any data, uh, I
just have an example that I can share with it, and
you're gonna see that it will prompt me
to how to generate uh the,
the data set.
First, it make sure that the use case
is the correct one.
So it gives me the spec, This is what I was referring
to in terms of spec driven development.
It tells me, hey, the business problem you want to solve is
to assist the business analysts and data analyst, what I
told you before.
It defines some tenets, tenets
for success.
The query needs to be correct, needs to be efficient,
needs to be explainable, needs to have a professional
tone. OK, maybe this is irrelevant.
Most importantly, it needs to be safety, so it
doesn't have to do any right queries
back to SQL, uh, that needs to be
a safe one.
If I don't like any of these specs, I can go ahead
and just edit, so I can go, for example,
here and change anything about the
description of the explanation, clarity. To
be honest, they're pretty fine. I'm gonna keep also the
professional tone, why not? So I'm gonna save and
approve.
Remember that whenever we do spec
driven development, your goal is not to just
blindly accept the spec that come from
the agent.
That spec is gonna be the one that drives
your use case, so make sure that it is aligned
with what you actually want to achieve.
So in just a second here, what's gonna happen
is that we are gonna jump, there we go.
So, let's create an example for your use case. If
you have any specific details about the space backset
behavior, blah blah blah, please share them now.
I do have something already.
Which is, uh,
there we go. I have an example,
so, this is an example that I can use to generate
more uh more examples here, sorry for the
repetition there.
So my prompt says,
you are an AI assistant tasked with answering
user questions with accurate SQL queries,
so I have a data schema. In this case, I only
have two tables, so it's gonna be very short, but
you can enrich this as you want.
And I provide it with a completion. So, a
SQL query
with a detailed examples.
So what's gonna happen now is that the agent
is gonna leverage this example that I give to it
to generate two more examples.
I'm gonna review them, and if I like them,
then I can define
these as the base for my spec
for data generation.
Let's look at the two examples that were given,
and you can see that the 3 examples
that are now in the chat,
they actually follow the style that I gave to the
agent. So, it has a prompt, which has,
let's say the system prompt per se,
the user input in terms of the query, in this
case find total sale and total quantity
for each region where total sales exceeds 1 million,
and the response in a well-structured
SQL query.
This looks good, so let's say yes, proceed.
So, as I say yes proceed now, what's it gonna
give me is that it's gonna tell me, OK, now
I understand how I'm supposed to create this data,
so let's please align to the,
uh, let's say, let's define together the
spec for how to generate data,
and we will use that spec to
create a certain number of examples.
So let's go through the spec first.
You see information about the use case,
definition, what's important about the data,
some of the examples, which are the ones that
we wrote before.
And finally,
quality standards. What does it mean to have a good
answer? What does it mean to have a bad
generation in this case?
Once again,
here I'm accepting everything blindly.
I'm not suggesting you do that. I'm suggesting you actually
go through the details here,
change anything that might be less relevant.
We try to make it as aligned as possible
to your use case,
but there's no one else out there that knows your
use case better than you.
So let's save the changes in this case and approve
the, the data spec.
And now what's gonna happen is they're gonna tell me, hey,
configure the synthetic data generation,
you know, for a good SFT use case, it's
suggested to, it's recommended to create 5000
records.
I'm gonna also use this
path.
Data the
demo, let's put it that way,
with a role ARN
which I have already handy here.
And if I have additional data which I can use as context
for the data generation, I can provide it here.
Right now I don't have any,
but I'm gonna start the synthetic data
generation. So what you're gonna see is that this is
gonna take a little while. So if you don't have
anything to do for the next 45 minutes,
we can wait for this to be completed.
Of course that's a joke. We have one already pre-done.
But what's important is that the data
generated will be stored in a tree.
It's gonna be Jline's format.
We can take a look at that in just a second,
and this, you can use it not just
as part of the AI agent experience,
but it can be used also with your own
training. To
make sure you guys are not waiting too long here,
because you have to attend a party tonight, so you
might not want to wait necessarily here until this
is done. I'm gonna show you
a complete end to end process, all right?
So, allow me to, you know, pull a
TV magic trick
and get one already done. So,
Data spec
Generation of the data. Data generation
is completed.
I can take a look at the generated synthetic
data. So, it's gonna give me
a couple of examples here, just the, the 1st
5 is gonna tell me that
generated 5000 records
for the SFT strategy, so it's gonna be prompt
completion pair.
They are correctly, you know, they have the uh
data schema in here as well as the
completions,
and you're gonna see all of these examples. If you want, you can look
it up online, uh sorry,
you can look it up in a tree to have the complete
list. But it also provides you with
data quality results. This is very important
because if you're doing any kind of training process, you
wanna understand how the data actually looks, not
just from a few
random samples, but actually get
statistics on your data set.
Get the N-gram diversity,
uh, get any of the, the, you know, the total
text, mean word length,
anything responsible AI metrics, this is very
important to make sure that we are aligned.
Toxicity score is super low, it's basically
zero, it's almost negligible.
In fact, there are 0 toxic records. This
should probably be like a 0 toxicity score.
Once that's done,
the very next step that the agent will suggest
is to start a training job.
And once again, we're doing it here just because we want
to showcase the AI agent capability, which is
available in private preview.
But again, you can take this data and use it anywhere
else. You could be using the UI that Summit
was just showing before, you could be using it in
your code, really, whatever you want. Any
of these components is modular,
and you can reuse it where you want.
For the training job, you have to configure a couple of
parameters like the batch size, learning rate.
We provide this value by default,
because we have tested a couple of recipes behind the
scenes. But again, these values depend
on the use case, on the complexity of the use case.
So you might still wanna have a little bit of knowledge of
data science.
Of course, I've already launched the training job
behind the scenes, so I can show you the full metrics.
As you can see, this was a job for 87
epochs,
epochs is complete,
lasted 6000 seconds. You do the math,
uh, I don't remember exactly how that what that is.
64 batch size,
7 epochs.
Learning rate very low.
Let's look at the metrics with the
new serverless ML flow.
You're gonna see that with a simple click of a button, without
even leaving, let's say the agent per se, I
can be rerouted to the ML flow. I'm
gonna get the list of experiments.
Spoiler alert, you're gonna see a lot of examples
here, because this is a shared account, so we're
using with a bunch of other folks out there.
But if I remember right, this is mine,
so it's the Lama SQL with systems prompt.
Promptly called Lama SQL because it's
a LMA model that generates SQL query.
Yeah, in tech we don't have a lot of imagination
for namings.
And so, I can go into the details of my experiment,
get the model metrics, get the system metrics,
etc. You can see
the, there's a pretty decent training,
uh, loss is continuously
falling, so, uh, converging
at some point, so that's good.
Uh, and you can take a look at all the different details,
uh, and go into much more,
uh, understanding of the different outcomes
from this training.
Once that is done, then what we can do
is that we can start the evaluation.
Now, once again,
the uh agent is gonna suggest a
spec for evaluation,
right? It's gonna give me some metrics that I could
be using if I wanted to,
to evaluate the performances of this model.
It's gonna take a while to run the er
to run the evaluation. I had to rerun it this
morning because of some clean up in this account.
Uh, as you can see, it's uh still a little bit
running, but you can see the progress. Basically
what it does, oh, there we go, there was an error, maybe I
changed something in there,
uh, but it will run,
uh, an LLM as a judge evaluation as well
as a custom scoring of what the,
uh, of what the model actually is
performing and will give me at the end of this
a nice report saying,
hey, this is how the model performs according to the metrics
that we have defined.
The metric, it defines itself, for example, in
this case, efficiency focus,
user friendly explanation, cost awareness,
those are all very generic and they require an LLM
to be confirmed,
uh, this, which is why we use LLM as a judge
behind the scenes. But again,
this has been approved as is. If you want, you can
go ahead and change
anything in it.
So, let's take a look at the model
results in general. So I'm gonna go once, once
again into the models tab here.
I'm gonna look at my models, gonna go through all
the different models that my colleagues have trained, and
I'm gonna look at mine, Lama SQL with
System prompt.
So, I have here at the scene, a single of
glass. I will have all the information
with respect to my model. So, what
did I train it on?
When was it trained? What is the training job that led
to this model? What was the training data set,
when this happened, which technique was it? What
was the base model, training hyperparametters,
performances of the model training as well, which
come directly from ML flow.
And then I can also take a look at the evaluation
report that I was telling you about before. It's still
going on, but we can take a look at the details later.
I can also go ahead and deploy this
model. This is really important because once
we have trained the model, as Summit was
telling us about before,
it's a model that has been fine tuned is
only valuable when you can actually put it into production.
So the very first, the very next step after
evaluating a model should be to
deploy.
And in SageMaker it's as easy as clicking
two buttons here.
Click the deploy button all the way up top
right, and then choose your technique.
Whether you want to deploy it in an end on an endpoint
on Sage Maker, runs 24/7,
always available,
uh, can scale horizontally as much as needed,
or deployed on Bedrock.
Rather than deploying, we should be saying import
in Bedrock, with the custom model.
Which will make it available in a server-less fashion,
and you will pay only for the kind of request that you
do. We tend to prefer
Sage maker when you have a certain threshold
of throughput that you want to meet,
because then you define the architecture, you define how
big the endpoint is gonna be, and you define how
many requests you can receive.
If your workload is spiky or you're still
more in a
development sort of fashion,
Bedrock is a great choice with custom model import
because it allows you to test,
understand, and further improve your model.
So, I can decide to create a new endpoint or
I use an existing endpoint.
I'm not gonna do that right now because I already have
many endpoints deployed here.
So you will see, uh, again, we are using a
shared account, so,
uh, no surprise there.
But what I'm gonna show you right now is
what can you do
once you have
deployed that model.
So, my model is available. Let me actually
clean up this code so we can walk
you through step by step.
So as we as we have deployed
our model, then the next step is to
use it for inferences.
The very first thing I'm gonna do is that I'm gonna create
some utility function. We can go
back into this in a second.
And uh what I wanna do now
is that my very first operation will be
to generate an inference just to test
if the model is actually working or not
on the endpoint, OK?
Of course,
we have trained it according to the best practices,
so it should be working just fine.
And in fact, I'm gonna use a SageMaker predictor SDK
here to generate an inference. You
see it was super fast.
And you can see that this model,
because I'm passing, uh, you know, I'm
passing it the information that it's, uh,
I'm passing it the system prompt saying
you are an advanced AI assistant,
your, your goal is to execute
a tool to generate,
to generate SQL queries and to execute them using
the tool.
And the query is, can you give me the top 3 markets
with the highest number of returns?
So, the model correctly replies by
saying, hey, you need to call a tool.
The tool is called execute SQL query. I've
created it at the beginning of this notebook,
and the SQL query you need to execute is
the select market count, blah blah blah, limit
3, OK?
Not exactly the most difficult SQL query
out there, but just for the sake of the demo it's gonna do
fine. Then
I can go ahead and test this query
to make sure that it works all right.
And as you can see, the output here is says
LatAM in my demo data set,
the market with the most return is LaTA with 296,
followed by APAC and the United States.
OK, you might say, David, this is nothing new, this is not an
agent because I had to call it manually.
So, how about we build an agent
with this?
So, we're gonna use reagent for our use
case, and the good thing about Streagent is that
it executes the tool behind the scenes,
and all they have to do is just
provide it with a system prompt, provide it with the tools,
pass it to query, and after a
couple of the query execution,
it provides me exactly the same result. As you
see. I didn't go through any steps of
defining what the tool code was. It did
everything automatically behind the scenes.
Final thing that I'm gonna show you, and then I'm
gonna let uh Nikhil come on stage
to talk about
uh good things that Robinhood is doing with
StageMaker AI.
The very last step is that, OK, now your
agent is running on the notebook,
that's not really useful. How about we put it
into production.
So, I wrote this little script
that basically what it does is that it defines
the same agent that I just defined, as you see
is the same strand agent configuration,
but additionally,
I have this
Bedrock Agent Core app definition.
This is all you need to add in order
to provide information on how to
run this agent in production
on Agent Core.
And in fact, you can see that as
I invoke my agent on agent
core with the prompt,
with the same kind of question, I will get my
output out saying, OK,
show me the number of orders that were returned for each market,
and if everything goes right,
then I have exactly the same response.
So, of course, we can re-look it up, you know, you
can try different queries, try different prompts.
The goal for me was to make you understand
how do you go end to end from chatting
with an agent to build a machine learning model,
so Gen AI model, a small language model.
And go all the way down to production.
This is ready to go to prod.
Please don't use this code in your production environment
cause this is still cory road, so, you know, you
might, you might wanna be
careful about that.
Alright, let's look at someone that actually
did good production level code with a
great team. Uh, so I'm gonna invite
Nico on stage to talk about, uh,
accelerating AI innovation at Robinhood.
Thank you, thank you, every day. Uh,
that was such a wonderful talk.
And, uh, my name is Nico Singhal.
I'm a senior staff ML engineer at Robinhood.
I lead our agentic platform initiatives,
everything from LLM evaluations to fine-tuning
infrastructures to inference systems
at production scale.
As I'm in an infrastructure team, uh,
the platform team,
we build capabilities to accelerate
gente
application development at Robinhood.
And we have built platform capabilities
that are
built over
Sagemaker AI and
AWS Bedrock.
We use SageMaker AI for training and
Bedrock for inferencing.
So, today, I'm going to talk
about
how we are accelorating AI development
uh through fine-tuning, but before that, let
me contextualize it.
I'll start with, like, Robin had started
with, uh,
a bold question from our co-founders, Bala
and Baiju.
What if finance were for
everybody, not just for ultra-wealthy?
This simple but powerful
idea sparked a movement, and
Robinhood broke all the barriers
with commission-free trading.
And we did not stop there. We extended
into crypto,
cash management, credit cards, and
recently stock tokens.
And enable access to
enable like for our users, we enable
access to, to the, to the market
in a way, once unthinkable.
Throughout our journey we stay true to our mission,
which is democratizing finance for all.
We build capabilities
which are simple,
ergonomic,
and empowering for users
so they can take full control
of their financial future.
Moving to our AI vision.
For us to truly
realize our mission,
we believe that we need to give
our users
the same level of support and
insight.
As a high net worth individual.
And for that we need to really harness
the transformative power of
AI and machine learning.
Therefore, AI
isn't just a feature for us,
it is one of the cornerstones for us
to fulfill our mission.
Let me walk you through some of the
applications which we have built,
uh, and which are one of the
complex applications.
Powering mission critical agentic apps, this is Cortex.
Uh, if you open
Uh, any stock trading app, you
will see like sometimes like, hey, stock is moving
up or down.
Before, you need to be really detective
that, hey, why it moved up, why it
moved down.
This is where we thought that AI can really
be that detective for you and for our users.
And it can crunch way
too much information and can
provide a unique, a cohesive
and useful information in a digestive
manner to our users. And this we
believe is very empowering and what we
believe is that
Enabling users to get the same level of
insight
what
somebody with a, with an extended team
would, would, would have received.
Customer support
is the other, other frontier where
we have built an LLM agent to
automate our customer support.
For users,
when they are dealing with trading, there are a lot of nuances,
there are a lot of other
support they need.
And that is where we thought that
Building an LLM agent for customer
support will be empowering for our users
because that is how we can scale and
provide users or
to answers to their questions.
Whether they are complex or whether they
are about exploration, a
product idea.
Our customer support agent is split
into 3
stages.
The first is the
Intent understanding where we for the
observability reasons and for the
downstream stages, we first
understand the intent of a user question. Hey, whether
it's a broker's question, whether it's a crypto question,
or whether it's
uh
like requires complex reasoning.
Then we move to planner
and the tool selection that, hey, to solve this
question, what kind of planning do I need?
What kind of tools or databases queries
I need to execute.
And at the end.
It, when it
makes, uh, when it figures out that this is the,
the, the plan it needs, it tests the tool invocations.
Once it does the tool invocation, it retrieves
all the context. Once the context is built, then
the final answer generation happens.
Many of the models here
do get served out of Amazon Bedrock.
Moving, moving forward, uh,
while we build these apps, we realize
that we need to scale them as well.
And that is where
I talk about generative AI trilemma.
In the, in the world of generative AI these
three variables cost
Quality, latency are often
fighting against each other.
You may think that the
Like sometimes you can throw a high-end hardware
to reduce your latency, but that
burns your cost budget. So the idea is
very simple. Like if you go with the quality,
you will need a high-end frontier model,
but that puts a lot of pressure on your
cost and latency.
But at the same time, if we are working with
a small size model, often you will
see that, and we saw in the previous session
as well, that there is a
quality hill climbing exercise
needs to be performed.
But for us,
this is even more challenging because we
are not building
single interaction
application. We are building LLMs, uh, agent.
These agents make any number of
LLM calls. So if
one of these stages.
I Either slow
or is inferior in quality,
the results are amplified.
That is why we had to be
methodological in terms of approaching,
uh, approaching and solving this problem.
Our approach here is,
we split into three categories. First,
we are very selective what
models to select.
For example, intent
understanding, that is one of the easiest,
relatively simpler
stages.
Why do we, we question, why do, do
we really need a high-end model for
that? Can we, can we work with a smaller
model? And that is where our approach is
always evolved first.
Whatever we do,
first evaluate and make sure and build
it, uh uh
uh uh like be cognitive about
that what
like model is the right fit here or
not. Then,
if we don't get the quality, like for an example in
the planner case and the tool selection case, which
where we kind of
understand that for a user question, these are the tools we need
to invoke.
If we don't get the quality
just by tweaking the prompt or optimizing
the prompt,
we inject a few short examples
which carry
high fidelity, fidelity with the
user cushion.
We call it trajectory optimization.
Once we have squeezed all the juice
out of the prompt tuning and trajectory tuning, and
we want to further
ah
dive into gaining more
Optimizing our cost or latency,
that at that point we go in fine tuning.
The idea is simple there.
Don't treat every problem as a nail, otherwise
we'll end up overutilizing the fine-tuning
hammer.
As the generative AI space is evolving, there
are a lot of problems still land in the fine-tuning
space where we end up doing cost and latency
optimization.
With that,
we have built, uh, I'll share the
fine-tuning platform which we have built at Robinhood
and where we, uh,
and how we are utilizing
AWS Sage Maker AI
and AWS Bedrock.
Every fine-tuning exercise
starts with a goal.
The goal definition has to be
clear. Often
you will see there may be
two goals, like, as I said, latency and
cost, but
we recommend, like what internally
we recommend,
have a primary goal.
Then once your goal is defined,
Do a base model selection. This is very
essential. And this can only happen once
we have an eval data set.
And the data set creation
is a challenging exercise.
If we, we, we say that
walk before you run is basically
spend some amount of time in
your data set preparation.
Your evals needs to be a
true reflection of your production use cases.
So it has to be well stratified. It
needs to have
good sample of complex use cases,
uh, and the, and the simple use cases.
Once we have selected a model,
Move to a dataset creation.
And the data set creation is an
extended exercise of how you would have created
an eval data set.
Same stratification exercise
that understood that, like, like for example
in the CXU scale which I talked about,
one of the dimensions which we utilize
is
Intent
Making sure that the questions which we
have are well diversified
across all intents.
The other
uh potential dimension here is
number of turns, whether the user
is a sing like a single turn question or a
multi-tone conversation with, with the, with the,
with an AI assistant.
Once we have the data,
move to the training, and this is where we have
a fork.
Today, we saw that there are a lot of
standard recipes which are available uh
on SageMaker.
We leverage those recipes,
and that is where we utilize Pacemaker
Jumpstart.
But if there are use cases which
require some customization,
for an example, your context length is, is
really long and your data set requires
a spatial handling.
At that point, we use
AI StageMaker AI Studio.
And you have the Jupiter notebook there,
you can attach to a P4DE instance
or a or a or a P5 instance,
and you can uh basically
get a machine for yourself.
Either way,
once you fine-tune your model,
you can serve it
through Bedrock,
and this is where we unify our serving
flow. We use custom model
import to import those models to
Bedrock, and once the models are imported
to Bedrock,
we integrate through our LLM gateway.
This is how
all of the applications at Robinhood
integrate with,
through LLM gateway.
So once the model is accessible through LLM LLM
gateway, it is available for our internal
playground, internal evaluations,
and, uh,
and, and for the production use cases.
So this is how we, uh,
operationalize the fine tuning and enab
and, and offer it as a platform capability
to our users.
Let me talk about the impact.
We, we have received more
than 50% of latency savings
uh through a fine-tuned model. Let me put it
in perspective.
Uh,
before we were for one of the planar stages,
we were using, uh,
a high-end model, and that was giving
3 to 6 seconds of latency.
And then at, particularly at
P90 and P90 95
or P90+,
we were able to cut down the latency heavily
and brought it under 1 2nd.
And with this validation,
Uh, once we have validated
this, we have started to extend it
to other set of agents,
and we are seeing, uh, trending results.
With that, I will invite uh Summit
and David.
Thank you. Cool.
Stay naked. You can stay here over us.
Thank you. Uh, thank you, everyone, once again
for coming all the way to Mandalay Bay on a Thursday
afternoon. Um, and thank you for
staying through the presentation.
Uh, please do, uh, go ahead
and, uh,
provide your feedback, uh, through the survey
in the app.
We would always, we love to go back and
look at all the feedback that you shared with us so we can
come back with better content and better presentations
every year.
Uh, we're gonna stay here for some more time
just to take any questions you might have.
Uh, please feel free to, uh, come to
the stage and, and, and, and we can chat away.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you.